hey youtubers is charlie happy comic-con
day one so the CW's been dropping promos
for flash season 3 so I'm gonna play
that we also learned about what's going
on with Jesse quick and harrison well so
i'll talk about that after the promo
knows hey and we're here and we're here
to answer your question all of your
quest itõs gonna bring them in Theodore
thank you from Jake gasps Jake is jesse
l martin yes why does Grodd hate bananas
why that's a damn good question i have
no idea i was God but he certainly does
hate him learn that real quick marked it
he lives in the sewer he shouldn't be so
picky anyway yeah what's down there to
heat really not many bananas given the
chance who would be your favorite
villain to fight well we had a lot of
them actually that I wanted to see on
the show already in the first season um
I I think a cool villain from the comics
tab on the show would be mirror master
because you do it that would open up an
opportunity to have like a whole other
world type of thing you like tequila can
like go into his world two mirrors and
whatnot e---coli yeah so he just opens
out of fun doors to have on the show her
you know just a lot of possibilities
that's not going to bootcamp that could
happen on CY now
with that outfit looks like yeah mirror
master cool I'm sure like a disco ball I
think maybe yeah that why not you should
be our country no you should've she's
great hahaha is great thanks Tom wait
that's Matt thanks Ethan thanks guys are
you watching did he really just imply
that mirror master would be coming on
this season not necessarily this was
actually done a long time ago like
they're just posting this now just you
know hi people up they've been posting
stuff like this week to week just to get
you crazy for actual season 3 footage
like Candace patent was like I would
really like to see iris be bad although
I think she was talking about being a
badass again like she was when she got
to be earth to iris but you know I think
a little bit of this is just having fun
mirror masters just one of the biggest
rogues that they haven't done yet but
because they were already doing an
alternate reality like earth to during
season 2 then you can see why doing
mirror world would have been completely
redundant so mirror world is the big
concept for me remastered like it's this
alternate reality with everything's just
kind of reversed slightly so I think
they're just waiting for the right
opportunity to slip that in but Evan
McCullough would probably be the one
that they would go Sam Scudder was the
first mirror master Evan McCullough was
the second Julian Dorne is the name of
the character that they announced for
tom Felton so that could be a mask for
that I initially thought that he was
playing doctor alchemy just because his
backstory that they teased was a little
bit closer to the second dr. alchemy who
worked with Barry inside the crime lab
mere met like there's no version of mere
master that's ever worked with Barry at
the crime lab but the flash TV show
always changes things so let you know
they're talking about Grodd here
obviously we know Grodd is coming back
he exists on earth to but if the
timeline has changed the reverse-flash
never came never created Grodd then
Grodd might be back on earth one they
also teased what's going on with
Harrison wells and Jesse quick now
they're both coming back I don't know if
Jesse quick is going to be a series
regular Tom Cavanagh still series
regular but neither of them is coming
back in the first episode and they just
said that well if the reverse-flash
never came back never assumed Harrison
wells identity then the original
Harrison wells is still alive so that's
probably who tom cavanagh is playing
this season the
digital version of Harrison wells that
we saw drink season one so we can still
probably say that his daughter is Jessie
quick but she might end up being earth
one Jessie quick we might meet her
mother I was always hoping that Tina
McGee would wind up being her mother we
never saw a picture of her but Harrison
wells is very clearly married to this
woman in the flashbacks that we saw in
season one so that will actually
probably end up being Jesse's mother but
what about the reverse flash then so the
yellow suit wearing reverse-flash EU
barth on will probably come back it will
probably be the mat lecher version of
the character because there's still a
very big story that we haven't gotten
yet and as this season is flashpoint if
you haven't read it there is a reverse
flash title that appeared during
flashpoint it's the story of how he
became the reverse-flash so like every
once in a while when they reboot a comic
they always retell origin stores like
they show a version of it so naturally
this version is just Geoff Johns doing
his version of it so we actually get to
see what it's like in the 25th century
where he's from how everything is
perfect things are so perfect that it's
incredibly boring so the reverse-flash
kind of rebels against that and that's
what sends him on the path to becoming
this villain like he's so upset by the
idea that everything is set in stone
predetermined like everything moves to a
very set schedule there's no deviation
from the mean so like all super villains
he feels completely under appreciated as
a child how come I can't do the things
that I want to do so he falls in love
with the idea of the flash and then they
kind of weave in elements of the classic
backstory where this time capsule
appears with Barry Allen's flash suit
with traces of the Speed Force in it so
he reverse engineers the accident
becomes the reverse-flash and then he
and Barry proceed to have their
adventures fighting against each other
so like in season 12 the flash when we
meet the reverse-flash we're kind of
seeing the end of that story where he's
like finally I'm going to kill Barry
Allen once and for all so he goes back
in time to try and kill him so a lot of
what we've seen from the reverse flash
on the TV show from the abarth on
reverse flash is only at the very end of
their adventure so like during season
two when he came back when we actually
saw the mat lecher come back he was
looking for Barry Allen he finally found
out where he existed in time that was
like a little bit earlier in his
timeline so season three you know
naturally we would just push even for
maybe we'll get to see TV show you Barth
on become the reverse-flash for the
first time get to see him recreate the
accident that just be like a really fun
one off episode but I know a lot of
people wondering about the new black
flash we'll probably see shades of that
in the season 3 trailer maybe a little
bit of it they're probably going to over
explain him they kind of tease zoom last
year so they're probably do the same
thing with his new black costume
reverse-flash I'm expecting them to
reveal his name like if he's going to be
called the black racer if he's going to
be called inertia or something else
it'll probably be something very big
from the comics I'm not expecting him to
be you Barth on I think you'd even
though flashpoint is changing a lot of
things like Wally West has powers now I
think they'll still let Matt let your
come back and beat you bars on so this
guy will be someone completely new
probably a villain more central to
Wally's storyline than two berries but
because they did say that when Harrison
wells and Jesse quick comeback that
would be with it you know like a special
twist I don't know if that means that
Jesse quick is gonna have speed force
powers too but they were building some
chemistry between her and Wally West so
when she does come back I think they
might give some elements of the Linda
Park Wally West romance to her but
because they haven't even film like the
third episode yet I'm not expecting to
see Jesse quick or even Harrison wells
in the trailer I think they're just
gonna tee up how things are different
like oh my God look I'm back everybody's
here but it's just a little bit
different like things are just a little
bit changed so I'm expecting the trailer
to drop Saturday night of course all the
DC TV shows or dropping trails like
Supergirl season 2 is going to drop a
trailer arrows dropping their trailer so
I'll be doing a whole bunch of trailer
videos on Saturday and that's just the
DC stuff there's also a bunch of Marvel
stuff dropping then to later tonight
though is sweet Christmas so Luke Cage
is having its panel I'm expecting them
to drop like the first big trailer so
hopefully if that happens I'll be doing
that video if not then I'll just do a
regular video for the panel itself i'll
talk about jessica jones season 2 i'll
talk about our fists and defender stuff
and there is a punisher TV series too
but it's pretty early in development so
i'm not expecting to hear any news about
that but yes punisher will probably be
part of the defenders so just reminder
DC giveaway still going on all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video i'll be
posting a whole bunch more DC videos as
the week gets on so there will be
in all the descriptions for my comic con
playlist just to make sure you guys
don't miss any of the comic-con stuff
there's gonna be a whole bunch of stuff
coming in the next couple of days so get
hyped there will be a whole bunch of new
footage what you guys wait for that
video to post you can click here to
learn all about the Marvel stuff that's
happening between the movies and the TV
shows comic-con and you can click here
to learn more about the flash season 3
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight